joseph père à ste mère du marigot mais
ce matin avec nous en tant que
vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération cap nord et présidera
également surtout de la commission eau
et assainissement bonjour joseph peraste
bonjour monsieur viol tombe aujourd'hui
terre de martinique 1ère et aussi aux
téléspectateurs
ainsi joseph perez le cap nord a choisi
un fermier sur cette question de l'eau
ce sera la société martiniquaise des
eaux il y avait deux candidats en liste
avis oui tout à fait il faut savoir que
depuis le 26 mai 2010 gîte un cap nord
donc à délibérer pour qu'il y ait une
nouvelle gestion de l'eau puisque
auparavant nous avions une gestion par
le fcna dont j'ai été le président et
une autre session par un autre syndicat
la ccn haut mais à partir de ça on a
décidé qu'il y ait une seule entité
et donc il y a eu cet appel à marcher et
donc le 21 juin 2018 il ya eu donc cet
appel à concurrence
les offres ont été remis en septembre
et puis ensuite la sélection s'est faite
le 1er octobre lien avec deux candidats
s m e et s mds alors l'asm eux choisi
après analyse par un cabinet d'études
puis après débat au sein de cap nord
pourtant des doutes des accusations
pèsent sur cet opérateur là on rappelle
que le comité citoyen du sud estime que
le prix de l'eau dans le sud c'est trop
cher avec l'asm jean luc touly qui est
un militant de l'association pour le
contrat mondial de l'eau président du
front républicain d'intervention contre
calonne la corruption estime qu'un à
l'asm il ya beaucoup de pas citer ça ne
vous a pas empêché de trancher non je
vais vous expliquer le bout quoi et
c'est là justement je demande à tout le
monde d'être attentifs car dans la
mesure où vous avez des hommes de bonne
foi venu pour travailler vraiment pour
que les martiniquais puisse recevoir de
l'eau dans des meilleures conditions
parce qu'il faut savoir que nous nous
avons fonctionne en toute transparence
il y à une société qui s'appelle la
cogip
attali leur étude le cabinet d'études
que le président de cap nord a confié
l'étude de ce marché il faut savoir que
c'est une commission de dsp délégation
de service public qui effectue l'analyse
des offres le 26 novembre et propose au
président d'entamer les négociations le
président entame des négociations avec
les deux sociétés le 27 novembre 28
novembre avec aseem oui et puis il se
débat de trois heures alors ce débat
comme on va y arriver il faut savoir
donc non mais je veux bien présenter les
choses il y à eut d'abord la commission
si oui des commissions qui se sont
penchés donc un premier niveau les
commissions et émis des avis ensuite les
commissions ont proposé une orientation
au président mais il faut savoir que
seuls le président a le pouvoir de
décision donc le président a décidé en
fonction des éléments présentés par
l'aco gîte puisque les conclusions
disait sm sort premier en termes de
prestations et smds deuxième à ce moment
dont le président va au devant de son
conseil ont composé de 52 53 ans je
crois très démocratique qui a eu lieu
mardi dernier avec des critères comme la
qualité de la prestation la technicité
et le prix alors il se trouve quand même
dans ce conseil communautaire 53 - ya
deux personnes qui ont pris la parole
oui ou non nestor azérot premier vice
président qui a dit non j'ai des doutes
mais je ne vais pas voter contre mon
président en profiter disons des
troubles politiques et plus lien justin
pamphile collègues du loret qui dit je
demande à la population d'être très
veille hâtif sur l'évolution du prix de
l'eau parce que rien n'est dit que ce
prix ne va pas changer c'est ce que vous
vouliez c'est ce que vous demandez à la
smb alors il faut savoir que ces deux
interventions
tous les deux ils ont raison
tous les lieux ont raison mais je ne la
jouent très plus tous les trois en
raison le président de cap nau dans son
orientation puisque à 54% des voix
c'est bien sa décision qui est passé
donc tous les trois ont raison c'est
assez bizarre mais c'est bill la réalité
alors côtes des îles du interviennent au
conseil communautaire c'est parce que
auparavant ils n'ont pas assez
d'informations puisque il ne
il ne participe pas aux commissions de
travail mais ils sont consultés in fine
est ce toi été mis à plat puisque nous
avons même eu des conférences vidéo avec
logique réclament au gîte où chacun et
même ces deux élus importants ont eu à
poser des questions et ils ont eu
réponse joseph perez est ce que vous
nous garantissez ce matin vous êtes sur
les antennes de la première que le prix
de l'eau n'évoluera pas pour les
habitants du nord vous pouvez l'affirmé
le garantir en tout cas je vois quatre à
venir puisque ce sera la durée du mandat
confié à l'asm que j'avoue 10 en 2010
est un conseil communautaire cap nau a
délibéré pour maintenir le prix de l'eau
tel qu'il était déjà fixé dans les
différents contrats d'ici le 19 mai
super est donc cap nord a pris un
engagement on les élus même ceux qui
sont intervenus là ils ont en même temps
puis l'engagement puisque ce vote a été
ce qu'il y ait ce vote à l'unanimité
donc oui nous garantissons aujourd'hui
que le prix de l'eau ne va pas changer
jusqu à la fin du contrat cette année
c'est un contrat que nous avons passé
avec à celle de 4 ans près puisque oui
c'était 12 ans nous sommes passés à
quatre ans donc c'est tout nouveau on
sent c'est vrai qu'il ya des
interventions à date à gauche mais il
faut retenir l'essentiel on sent cette
volonté avec le président de cap nord
monsieur monthieu de maintenir pour le
moment avant de posséder peut-être à des
baisses parce que c'est ça notre
orientation mais de maintenir
depuis de l'eau dans l'état jusqu'à la
fin de ce contrat de quatre ans
premièrement deuxièmement d'amener un
sang nouveau pour que l'on puisse
bénéficier de travaux de réparation de
modernisation des réseaux
ce sont des choses qui n'étaient pas
faites auparavant évolué
nous sommes là c'est alors c'est une rue
les débuts de ces quatre ans oui l'idée
de l'art est davantage une régie alors
premièrement cela voudrait dire que on
aura plus de fermiers comme par le passé
c'est la collectivité elle-même qui
emploiera le personnel c'est clair c'est
la collectivité elle même qui donne à sa
politique de gestion et aussi nous
aurons nous serons plus souvent sur le
terrain les élus car c'est très
important que les élus soient sur le
terrain c'est là où je dis que
aujourd'hui nous aurons à être des gens
sérieux devant cette population qui nous
a élus ne remonterait qu'à chaque fois
qu'ils posent les transports notamment
pour d'autres c'est peut-être peut-être
vous savez nous sommes tous unis qu'elle
n'est sérieux aujourd'hui de
martiniquais doute beaucoup mais ils ont
raison de se voit pas si longtemps que
ça à ce micro il y avait monsieur pakit
ils vont pas quitte le président d'audi
ci qui disait que les élus martiniquais
ont raté le coche vers cette autorité
unique de l'eau est ce qu on y va
l'autorité unique de l'eau je pense
qu'elle est inévitable qu'est-ce qu'on
discute en ce moment pour cela en ce
moment les présidents des trois pci
l'espace sud kacem et kaplan discutent
sur cette affaire d'ailleurs je pense
que in fine et l'orientation peut être
positive mais ils mettent des conditions
et les conditions c'est d'abord que l'on
fasse car acheté château dauzac voilà
nos packs acheté cher de l'histoire du
cyclisme ça pèse
mais la dette de suez il est même pas du
6 août problème de or le problème du
transfert de compétence de l'eau que
nous a été imposée sans aucune
préparation oui ça a posé problème et
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui nous disons
que pour l'entité unique nous paca
prochain un soc
ouais pourquoi parce que nous voulons
d'abord faire un état des lieux et c'est
cela s'est su cela qu'on ne veut pas
encore travailler il faut que les
autorités responsables de l'eau toutes
les autorités tous les partenaires
soient d'accord pour qu'on fasse d'abord
un diagnostic connaître savoir découvrir
ce que nous allons accueillir ce que
nous allons
recevoir et ce sur quoi nous aurons à
travailler
je sais donc c'est la condition première
ouais pourquoi cette entité de l'eau
puisse exister
lorsqu'on regarde tout ce qui se passe
autour de l'eau dans le sud ont
l'impression qu'ils une sorte de
discrédit sur tout ce qui est politique
concernant la gestion de l'eau
concernant le territoire de la cacem
faut peut-être d'être des appuis
politiques très très fort pour que
quelque sorte des rangs finalement le
futur responsable de cette autorité
unique de l'eau pourrait venir de cap
nord ça pourrait être l'actuel président
de la commission eau et assainissement
tas de le président c'est à dire oui
même nom commission eau et
assainissement
sur un plan personnel ça vous
intéresserait de relever ce challenge
sur un plan personnel n'empêche que je
travaille simplement faire l'ombre vous
fait hara-kiri ce matin non pas du tout
je le dis parce que on n'y a jamais
pensé je vous ai avoué tout à l'heure
que les présidents roger je vais je te
dis que les présidents travailler
maintenant si écoutez les gars se disent
peyras et il est tout nouveau il est
arrivé il n'a l'air d'un gars série fait
un bon travail et qu'on leur proposera
homme de devoir
mais oui écoutez je suis entré en
politique parce que je suis un homme de
devoir
vous savez quand on s'engage en
politique c'est il faut y aller et je
crois l'avoir fait je crois pour
aujourd'hui après cinq ans que je suis
arrivé à la tête d'une municipalité et
aussi à cap non puisque si on a fait de
moi le président de le premier
vice-président de le d'assainissement
c'est pas pour rien
jusque y en avait d'autres qui ont géré
l'eau et l'assainissement à bon moi donc
je crois savoir que c'est peut-être un
personnage qu'on découvre et puis qui
s'est mise vraiment au service du peuple
et qui fera ce qu'il faut donc si je
suivais qu'isis youn et oui oui c'est
possible
ouais la question de l'eau doit être
prise très au sérieux par les politiques
parce que la population attend les
politiques là dessus tout à fait merci
beaucoup
joseph père est d'avoir été avec ton
rappelle que vous êtes vice-président de
cap nord et président de la commission
eau et assainissement promettait d'être
un homme de devoir sur fait appel à vous
merci merci merci et bonne journée
donc